FLORINA MUNTENESCU: Hello.
I'm Florina Muntenescu
for The Developer Show.
This is your update about
the coolest developer news
from Google in the last week.
In partnership with
Udacity and Andela,
we're offering
15,000 scholarships
to aspiring and professional
developers across Africa.
If you're interested
and want to learn more,
take a look at the post
and follow the links
to the application.
Google believes everyone should
be able to access and enjoy
the web.
Which is why we've open sourced
GTXiLib, an accessibility test
automation framework for iOS
under the Apache license.
Head on over to the post
for the Github link.
We recently worked with MongoDB
to expand the availability
of MongoDB Atlas on
Google Cloud Platform,
making it available
across most GCP regions,
as well as on Cloud Launcher.
[INAUDIBLE] how it
works with the post.
Chrome 66 beta is here,
with CSS-type object model,
[INAUDIBLE]
synchronous clipboard
API, the audio worklet
object, and more.
A full description and code
are available on the post.
We made more than 20
security announcements
across the Google Cloud
portfolio at last week's CEO
Security Forum in New York,
covering VPC service controls,
Cloud Security Command Center,
access transparency, and more.
For a lot of in-depth
details and a bunch of links,
head on over to the post.
Back in December, we announced
that the Firebase Realtime
Database had integrated
with Google Stackdriver
to let you create dashboards and
graphs of powerful new metrics.
We've now made all of this
data actionable through Google
Stackdriver Alerts.
Find out how to
set and customize
the alerts from the post.
We've been working
hard to make Firebase
more valuable for all
you game developers.
Last week, we stopped by the
Game Developer Conference
in San Francisco to
share some announcements,
including Google Play Games
Services support in Firebase
Auth, desktop support for C++
end-unit development, and more.
More details, and a link to the
documentation is on the post.
Please remember to like,
subscribe and share.
I'm Florina Muntenscu
for The Developer Show.
Thank you for watching.
And I'll see you next week.
SPEAKER: OK.
Developer Show with Florina.
Scene one, take one.
[CLAPPING]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[LAUGHTER]